what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing our discussion
on Earth X and again like Earth X God
you guys really seem to enjoy I love it
too it's a really really cool take on
like an alternate universe and Marvel
Comics but what this part does is we
initially pick up with the Asgardians
now this is kind of a cool thing and the
main Marvel Universe the Asgardians are
just sort of attributed to gods who
exist in a different dimension and
that's really about it what earth x does
is it makes them a lot more grounded and
tangible now one of the big things that
people do is they kind of make the
mistake of taking the earth backstory of
the Asgardians and believing that's the
main Marvel Universe story they're not
exactly identical instead in earth X
what we end up finding out here is that
the Asgardians are basically aliens and
they derived themselves from from
shapeshifters but the funny thing is
that because they were shapeshifters
they had no true identities they
eventually arrived on earth and when
they did they encountered humanity and
humanity gave the Asgardians forms and
so it's kind of interesting because
while they are perceived as gods in the
eyes of humanity and they operate as
gods in the eyes of humanity there are
actually prisoners of humanity the story
actually hits on the nature of Ragnarok
that's one of the questions asked here
won't Ragnarok be the end times of the
Asgardians but the reason why Ragnarok
will exist is not because it's a totally
separate set of circumstances that
involve Serdar and all these things and
will inevitably happen to the Asgardians
outside of the fates of humanity instead
Ragnarok is defined as the end times of
the Asgardians meaning Ragnarok will
come when humanity ends when the world
is destroyed and the reason why is
because when the world is destroyed
humanity will be destroyed with it and
there'll be no one left to give these
various as Guardians any real appearance
or anything
ee no one left to basically guide them
on what they should be as the result is
that they will most likely just kind of
self-destruct or they'll just go on to
become something else but regardless the
Asgardians quote-unquote will
effectively come to an end and that's
kind of the cool thing here it takes
this origin story it kind of turns it
around a little bit it shifts it around
but everything else remains intact
Thor was eventually banished from Asgard
nor to learn humility Loki was the
trickster Odin was the king of all the
Asgardians all that kind of stuff you
know it's cool because a lot of that
history still remains intact but at this
point we switch back over to Latveria
basically to castle doom now again
because of the fact that Reed Richards
had been masquerading as Victor Von Doom
and the Inhumans had arrived back on
earth looking for the husband of
the daughter of a Quicksilver and
crystal what this meant was that when
Reed Richards basically left to go find
cerebra the device that was used by
Xavier to locate mutants suddenly all
these doom bots start activating
believing that these people are
basically threats that are not supposed
to be here and the fight it's pretty
straightforward I mean there's not a
whole lot to go on with it but something
that I want you guys to notice here is
they don't make any moves towards Black
Bolt it's like he's not there and the
question is initially asked but the
answer is this kind of left lingering
and so at this point we switch back over
to California to Los Angeles now I
remember
Los Angeles is basically the home of the
skull this young kid who developed the
power of mind control and is working to
essentially kind of be the new red skull
so to speak or at least adopted the
insignia of the red skull and has been
essentially consolidating power now
because of the fact that he has the
power of mind control what this means is
that anyone who just kind of stumbles
across his path any wayward person who
travels to LA for whatever reason will
basically be ensnared inside a sphere of
influence and the result is that they'll
become his pawn but in the midst of all
this Captain America is meant by the
arrival of daredevil now remember this
is a person masquerading as daredevil
it's not actually Matt Murdock we'll
find out who this person is but it is
cool because this guy basically shows up
and so he says look I'll join you cap on
your mission I mean you're gonna fail
but like I want to be there to be a part
of this whole thing that you're doing
the whole motivation behind this guy
showing up joining Captain America is
that his audience has been stolen from
him it seems to be the only real
motivation but notice it's kind of
nonsensical and it's kind of silly which
should give you a little bit of insight
into who daredevil is at the moment but
the other half of this is that Captain
America has basically come across a
handful of mutants that exist inside of
Los Angeles and so what he actually ends
up doing is sending these guys directly
over to Cyclops now we'll pick up with
that here in a second but at this point
we jump over to the new sorcerer supreme
clear now remember Clea is basically the
the nice more or less of Dormammu but
we're not really told what goes on with
door mama we're not really told what's
going on with his character or anything
like that what we are told is that at
some point along the line Steven strange
is spiritual essence had like gone out
into you know the the astral plane and
something had happened where it's
believed that his spiritual essence has
been destroyed what this does is it
basically leaves his body without a soul
and the result is that Clea was the one
who took up the mantle of the new
sorcerer supreme and they're just kind
of hoping Doctor Strange comes back
eventually but the whole idea of Bruce
Banner showing up here with the
honk is to basically say like they had a
dream and the dream was that they
essentially encountered Marvel of the
Kree now remember Marvel was it was the
original Captain Marvel in Marvel Comics
in Marvel's main continuity he died of
cancer that was a story that was written
by jim Starlin 1984 and he was gone it
was a way to ride him out and basically
try to find a way to replace him with
somebody else which ultimately became
Carol Danvers but the whole gist of this
is that he essentially appeared a to
Bruce Banner it's kind of like Ian more
or less is a cosmic entity but what
Bruce Banner sort of derived from this
was that earth was was destroyed more or
less that you know when he looked him to
Eon and he saw the galaxy or the
universe inside of eon and he looked for
earth earth wasn't there anymore because
earth had been destroyed and that's what
they're trying to find out is what
happened to the planet Earth now Bruce
Banner views this as kind of a spiritual
message you know like Marvel reaching
out from beyond the grave to try to warn
Bruce Banner of something and so the
whole idea of approaching clea is to
basically say like we're looking for
passage into the realm of mistress death
we want to go to her realm we want to
contact Marvel and we want to see if he
was the one that sentenced this message
or if it was just a crazy dream that I
had but it is kind of cool because in
this world of all kinds of crazy thing
flights of fancy you know and these
people with incredible powers and so on
and so forth it makes sense it like that
would be a legitimate question now at
this point we switch over to what we
basically switch over to Thor this is
kind of a funny thing when it comes to
earth ax earth X made a lot of
predictions about the future of Marvel
Comics in terms of like different
characters we would see in this story
Thor is a woman now Thor was turned into
a chick by Loki that's the whole basis
behind his it was a trick that was
played by Loki on Thor now this also
deals like the storm Giants basically
invading and theta taking care of pretty
quickly by Thor and the result is of the
iron Avengers basically go out and do
something else
it was a huge trick that was played by
Loki to kind of teach Thor humility even
after he was on earth but the idea is
that or can never go back to Asgard and
tell odin what happened because if that
were to take place then this spell of
Loki would banish Thor from Midgard for
all eternity he would never be able to
come back again and so it's basically
one of those things where like I'll stay
on earth as a chick you know I basically
just be a woman here as opposed to never
being able to come back but at this
point we end up switching over to two
Cyclops and the whole idea of Cyclops
really staying on earth even though he
doesn't need to is largely done because
of the fact that he's hunting for Jean
Grey now
initially he's approached by like his
father and he's approached by what looks
like Polaris and then havoc which is
basically like a family so to speak you
know a family of sorts but they're kind
of like hey look man we can take you off
earth it's essentially this idea that
like Cyclops could leave if he wanted to
but he's looking and trying to see
there's a way for him to get Jean Grey
back so we know jeans not dead but
that's kind of like where his loyalties
lie but ultimately the reason why Jean
isn't with him is because she's with
Wolverine in this story she got with
Wolverine and where we would expect a
kind of you know maybe like a Bonnie and
Clyde kind of situation or scenario
where like they're off having adventures
or they live a really dangerous life
instead they'd have like the crappiest
life imaginable she just sits at home
all day long and like he just drinks
beers all day long and that's it they
just loaf around and not actually doing
anything with their lives but it is
interesting to see this take because for
the most part when people imagine you
know Jean Grey going with Wolverine I
get like we said they usually kind of
imagine this this sort of life were like
they're out doing crazy things we never
really imagined them just kind of
settling down in their lives going
nowhere but ultimately what is up
happening is we basically have this this
point whereby we jump back to the castle
of Victor Von Doom and Carnac hits on a
very important thing of course Karnak is
a member of the Inhumans who actually
never went through terrigenesis at least
not in the main Marvel continuity
there's no indication that he went
through it here in this story but
carnac's basically very good at like
figuring out the quote-unquote weakness
of things figuring out the problem with
any one particular situation or like a
structure or something along those lines
but his line of logic has led him to one
inevitable conclusion it was not the
implementation of vibranium that led to
like everything going on here instead
the only indication here is that this
involvement of vibranium is a byproduct
of the fact that like it mutated people
like in Wakanda for example it turned
like Panther into like an actual Panther
but like that's about it but that was a
mutation that was going on for like
decades
you know before T'Challa ever can't ever
became black panther and as that was
progressing the issue here is that in a
matter of almost overnight people
suddenly develop powers and so in the
mind of Karnak and has nothing to do
with vibranium by Brady I may have been
the catalyst but it had nothing to do
with vibranium and so that's kind of the
mystery here is if Reed Richards is
wrong if he's basically incorrect about
what it was that gave everybody on earth
powers then the question is what was it
that made this happen but again from
here we jump to a bit of history on the
x-men and that's what's kind of cool
about this
with each story or I guess each issue
that comes out you get a little bit of
history about things that were going on
in terms what was going on in the past
now there are these little backup
features that are really more text than
actual imagery they kind of tell you
what was going on with particular
characters you know for example gambits
dead
Iceman went into his ice form and
couldn't go back to being into a human
form and so if you were to leave the
North Pole he would essentially melt and
so he just stayed to the North Pole in
isolation all the time I mean just
different things like that you know
these these small little paragraphs they
kind of tell you what's going on with
other characters but the overall idea
here is that when it comes to the x-men
one of the things that's kind of hit on
here is a philosophical differences
between Charles Xavier and Magneto now a
lot of this is just kind of par for the
course you know for those of you guys
who are familiar with the characters you
kind of know what they're about but it
is kind of cool because what this does
is it indicates the idea that Magneto's
plan to essentially take down the x-men
was a lot more intricate than the way it
is in the main Marvel Universe and the
main Marvel Universe it's I am the
leader of the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants and I'm going to implement this
plan and the x-men intervene and the
x-men defeat me my Brotherhood and I
retreat and I do it all over again but
the whole idea here is that it's
basically this this notion that humanity
looked at mutant kind basically and they
saw magneto as a necessary evil in the
sense that with the rise of the x-men
these various you know super-powered
beings who were out there by virtue of
an X gene with things like Scott Summers
and Jean Grey having a blossoming
romance because of the idea that they
would you know could conceivably
procreate what it meant was that with
the procreation of mutants humanity
would begin to basically fade away
mutants will begin to replace them and
so because of this humanity looked at
Magneto instead we said well maybe
magneto will basically instigate like a
gene war there'll be a war that'll take
place among all the mutants and they'll
basically destroy themselves and things
will be that simple and it is kind of
cool because that was the plan of
magneto in a lot of different ways the
plan of magneto was sitting down and
realizing that Charles Xavier dream of a
peaceful coexistence was too good for a
lot of people to ignore and so what
magneto did is by playing the villain he
made Charles Xavier into the good guy
and the whole gist of this is that as
the good guy Charles Xavier has to walk
the good guy path and what that means is
the first time he fails the first time
he falters the first Honey makes a
mistake suddenly everybody's on him well
he's not the good guy anymore he's just
as bad as Magneto and if he's just as
bad as
Magneto then why not just go join
Magneto that was the whole idea was
pretty intelligent and pretty smart the
way the whole thing worked out but again
Reed Richards is kind of visiting what's
left of the Xavier Institute which has
long since been in shambles essentially
grab cerebro for the purpose of going
through and examining everything and
trying to figure out if there's a way
for him to basically locate the inhuman
gene more or less and then allow the in
human family to sort of rise to
prominence again and then all the
Inhumans on earth to leave along with
the royal family that's really kind of
the immediate purpose that he's serving
here but then we switch over to Cyclops
himself and this is cool because what we
end up finding out is the the small band
of mutants that Captain America had run
into in Los Angeles were rounded up by
Captain America and synthesize offs in
order to be trained but notices Cyclops
is initially adverse to it I mean all
these guys basically attack him all at
the same time and that was just designed
to say hey look here's how far we are in
our training here's how advanced we are
but like Cyclops doesn't really want to
train these guys I mean he does but
basically he doesn't want to fall in
line of being Charles Xavier because in
his mind it's repeating the same thing
that happened before that like people
are gonna gain power you know people
have Hera like they had before but
training these people on how to use
their powers would basically train them
on how to use their powers so they could
use them nefariously they could walk
away and become villains more dangerous
villains than they were before they met
Cyclops any number of these various
circumstances that could arise but
ultimately he ends up going with it just
because of the fact that it gives him
motivation it gives him purpose notices
for a lot of the older people who were
here Captain America Cyclops these guys
it's doing what they can to latch on to
the last vestiges of what they remember
from like the way things used to be
hoping things go back to the way they
were before clinging to the past I'm
able to look into the future and so what
we end up doing here is coming back over
to the whole idea of Bruce Banner and
the Incredible Hulk and all these guys
basically trying to find a way into the
realm of mistress death now one of the
things that's kind of hit on here when
it comes to clear is that mistress death
as she exists here is a lot more evil
than she exists in the main Marvel
Universe and the main level universe she
toys with people but it's one of those
things were like she's willing to barter
there's been times where mistress death
has actually allowed souls to leave the
realm of the dead if she gets something
in return of significance and miss it
doesn't work that way
and this it's once you're in the realm
of the dead you're in there forever and
if you go walking into her realm and you
have a soul she'll take it and you'll
literally just be stuck there for all
eternity you'll never be able to leave
she'll never let you leave so she seems
very vindictive very evil you know very
very cruel and
cynical but the whole idea is that Bruce
Lander basically says on the Incredible
Hulk in there and on the surface that
seems pretty cold-hearted but this is
when we find out that the Incredible
Hulk isn't is basically the soul of
Bruce Banner I'm sorry Bruce Banner I
guess is the soul of the whole and so
it's basically this idea that like the
Hulk is its own entity
they can think and feel different things
like that if it goes into the realm of
mistress death as long as Bruce banners
on the outside then like there's no risk
of stealing the Hulk soul because
the Hulk's soul is on the outside it's
in the form of Bruce Banner and so it's
the best way to get somebody in there to
figure out what's going on the problem
with this is the incredible Hulk's not
the sharpest tool in the shed
now Banner believes that he's basically
managed to reconcile this information by
essentially like writing to the Hulk and
basically like giving him a message in a
bottle so to speak so that when the
Incredible Hulk is there he can crack
this open he can examine it and
basically take a look at things and just
sort of figure out what's going on but
at this point we switch over to high
club sort of training these x-men to a
degree it's a small moment but again
he's kind of stepping into the role of
Charles Xavier he prefers to be called
mr. s but he's stepping into the role of
Charles Xavier that's basically what he
is now he is a person who has stepped
into the role of a leadership capacity
by circumstance not really by actual
choice but he's maintaining this choice
in kneel in in the end that's really
kind of the motivation behind it the
basis behind it so it is cool but what
we end up doing is basically following
up with Captain America and daredevil
while they're essentially racing trying
to stop this mob of people from like
getting to New York basically trying to
control the sphere of influence of the
skull but the way this ends is
essentially them just like going into a
tunnel that's really about it but what
daredevil basically hints at is that he
can be dismembered he can be taken apart
piece by piece and then reassembled
again basically heal himself so again
gives us a little bit of indication who
daredevil is and you know in the earth X
universe but it is cool the ending is a
little lackluster from from the ones
that we've seen before but it still
stands on its own two feet and it's
still pretty solid I mean it's more just
kind of like world-building than
anything else but with that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
Oh